thank you and thanks to the organizer
for the invitation this very nice
workshop and very nice place so today I
would like to tell you about a very
recent work we have done with other
German mardana under montanari which
appear essentially in these two prints
and now we're appearing yes and another
conference proceeding and so what is the
essentially the outline of the talker I
would like to start from a problem a
prominent which has been already
introduced by many of the speakers which
is essentially community detection
problem i would like to convince you
that the spectral method may have some
problems and many optimization method
based on on another different kind of
relaxation are better in terms of
robustness and at the same time are
almost optimal and then i will show you
the performance of this sdp based
algorithm just to convince you that it
works it works very well and then
finally in the second half of the taco
glad to convince you that we can even
compute the agreement threshold for this
algorithm and so is robust and Kwazii
optimal in some spots difficult cases ok
so I don't have to convince you that the
community detection provides interesting
because half of this audience is
studying it so I will skip this but let
me just focus on to where feature that
in my opinion are essential so we want
the community faction agram to be
optimal in the sense that when you run
it on a random ensemble it takes the the
Eden community as soon as you can but at
the same time you want to be robust so
if you take a random graph and you
perturb it you want the ugly to return
an answer which is close to the one in
the purely random case ok otherwise it
would be difficult to use it in real on
real data ok so as a benchmark for the
random purely random case I will
consider the stochastic block model
which has been already defined by many
of the speaker Chris yesterday not so
today Mark and so this is just to show
you my notation so we consider n nodes
and Q groups of equal sides and then you
put edges with two different
probabilities depending whether the two
nodes belong to the same group of
different groups and I will stick mostly
to the assorted model where the the
inner connectivity is larger okay so
essentially these the problem the
problem focusing on to convince you that
is interesting to study so you take an
adjacency matrix and you feel it the red
region denser than the orange part but
then you remove the colors you remove
the ordering and you ask someone to
recover from this unordered and
unlabeled adjacency matrix the original
matrix with the communities ok so this
our problem and in am annotation I call
X not the true partition so the one you
built into the into the graph and X hat
is the estimated partition returned by
by different sophistical estimator and
we measure the quality of the inference
via this scalar product between the
original and they infer partition ok so
this essentially is the fraction of
notes correctly identified by the by the
inference algorithm ok so what are the
relevant parameter I will mainly
concentrate on the q equal to equal size
stochastic flawed model where for which
we have very nice result on on the bias
optimal inference the two relevant
parameter in these problems are the mean
degree and the signal-to-noise ratio
okay so the mean degree essentially tell
you what how sparse is the problem so if
these very large day the problem is
denser and is somehow easier than the
the diploma in the very sparse regime
and the signal-to-noise very sure is
such that you can
prove that in the bias optimal framework
there is a special phenomena atlandis
equal one such that for London smaller
than one is impossible informatica
little reticle impossible to detect a
leaden partition while for lambda larger
than the one you can and actually it has
been proved that an algorithm based on
beef propagation can return a novel up
larger than zero ok so this day all this
has been obtained by very ingenious
spectral method that mark today and told
us about and they but the question is
essentially a what happen if you don't
know exactly the generative model so all
this can be done if you know the
generative model at underlined the graph
that we are young you are working on but
if you have no information about the
generative model and you only know very
few things for example that they the
model is a sort atiba so nodes in the
same class that are more connected up
and notes between clusters and for
example that you have to equal sized
groups just to make computation easier
and the best thing you can do is to
maximize the likelihood which actually
amongst to maximize this quadratic form
and subject to the constraints that the
sum of the of the of the variables is
equal to zero in order to satisfy the
two equal-sized group the various that
this progress np-hard this essentially
the mean cut problem discussed by dembow
yesterday and and so you have to relax
this problem to make it tractable
otherwise you are not able to to to
solve it so let me rewrite the problem
in a Lagrangian formulation so you want
to maximize this faction fixing these
constraints introduce a Lagrange
parameter and as long as the Lagrange
parameter is large enough the
maximization of this Lagrangian happened
at the point where the sum of the X is
zero in particularly if you take this
parameter which is equal to the mean
degree of the graph actually you can
define this centered matrix which is
nothing but the matrix minus the average
value such that the mean value of the
matrix is zero and then you can maximize
this quadratic form without the
constraint ok so this what would like to
do steve is np-hard is just a
reformulation of the problem of the
previous slide and so we have to start
with some relaxation otherwise the
problem is unsolvable for very large n
so what spectrally access andaza
essentially we try to maximize this
function instead of maximizing on the
set of all these discrete points you
maximize over the entire either cube
which is a convex space so you can
easily and maximize this function and
then you compute this amounts to compute
the eigenvector the Prince Valiant
vector of the centroid matrix and once
you compute this prince malagant vector
you project back in one of the vertices
of the hyper cuba which is one of the
set of possible solutions by just taking
design oh this is fine as long as they
all the components of the principal
again vector are similar but if the
Prince elegant better stats will have
components very different this
projection is unlikely to give you the
right result and it is this is actually
what happened if you look for example
you do pc aaron a sparse matrix as long
as the degree is very large you see that
the two and the component of the
principal eigenvector are very much
correlated to the partition the blue and
the red are directed to different
partition while if the degree is very
small sorry if the degree is very small
then your localization and they the
component of the principal green vector
are more or less useless for
understanding the underlying partition
so the reason why this happen is is well
known if you can write the central
matrix
has a rank one matrix bringing the
signal plus a random matrix and if you
study the spectrum of these random
matrix you realize that well for lucky
you have this big nurse a musical oh but
for small degrees you have a tailor with
local I second vector and this is the
where the problem comes term arise so a
PC a phase for this reason people know
this and so invented new spectral method
but all the metal base on on the desing
cymatics they they are spotty mother and
in particular you can prove that many of
these as a a treasure which is strictly
larger than 1 until very recently all
this author proposal a new spectral
meadow which is much better in the sense
that well I don't want to spend too much
time on this because we already have the
talk by mark on on this but essentially
these new matrix ago it's some kind of
localization essentially because you do
number tracking paso you you are not
going a forwarding background a on the
highly connected nodes so and thanks to
these you can prove that these two
algorithms for non backtracking mattox
and debilitation which is equivalent a
much much easier because this matrix is
symmetric so all the spectrum is real
they can achieve our ultimate ii ok so
these very nice unfortunately if you try
to apply this spectral method which are
optimal for random graphs on non random
or quasi run on grabs you realize that
there are some problems in particular
let me define this quasi random graph in
the following way you generate a graph
according to the stochastic block model
so a purely random graphs then you
choose a a small very small subset of
size alpha of nodes and you build a
click around each of this
all fraction of notes and you expect
since the number of edges that we are
adding east is a fraction alpha times D
you expect that if alpha is much smaller
than 1 over d the result of the
inference method should not change it
should not be let me say you should not
modify sensibly by the addition of this
tiny fraction of edges and factually
this is not what happened and suppose
that I i'm looking here today the
inference provided by the petition just
because it's much simpler is symmetric
matrix where you have to compute the
second eigenvalue and the second
eigenvector the second eigenvector is
this one and as you can see is in the
case with no clicks added is very much
correlated with the partition okay so
the the eigenvector is very much related
with the partition look that we are on a
very large graph very close to the
threshold so 1.1 the threshold is at one
indeed the overlap is modest and is less
so 39 / % of the of the nodes are
collected in fact there is that now if i
add a very tiny fraction of clicks so in
this case alpha is is 10 to the minus 3
so is much smaller than 1 over d which
is one-third and what happened to this
eigenvector is that it gets localized
and so essentially the overlap with the
original edem partition is practically
zero okay so this just the second
eigenvector so I asked myself maybe the
other guy in vectors still bring some
information unfortunately if you look at
the entire spectrum these are d I came
back I ghen values what happened is that
all this negative tail edge is due to
this a newly added noise on top of the
random graph and so even if you look at
all these 30 I ghen vectors known is
bringing information you have to move
into the bike okay but then you have
start beginning
the back in order to find an eigen
vector which is bringing information is
not very convenient okay so this is the
problem of the spectral relaxation so
let's yeah we thought about this a
little bit with the non backtracking
paper and I mean it's a little bit of a
philosophical issue right so these
cliffs are very small but they're also
incredibly dense compared to the rest of
the graph so you know at some level the
fact that a community consider they
clicked ebay's for notes all right well
that is really very small so i would say
that is so dense well not forming a
tetrahedron so I i essentially added and
less than 100 the tetrahedrons in a
graph of 10 to the 10 to the 5 notes
okay I I guess I'm just trying to say
that clicks are they are communities
that would jump out at you yeah you know
to reconstruct the groups of four head
essentially these 50 eigenvectors are
each one a localizer on each of the
clicks that you picked up looked at by a
natural out whenever a row right yeah
but you modified the output ottoman
because you know what is the pepto i
knows what is the vendor patient here
you should modify the generative model
in order to take into account that and
then if and you know is a rice you have
to modify it again and you can do
everything but you have to make a much
more general answers so let's see what
we can do without to rely on the
generative model okay so we try to do a
different kind of relaxation next EP
relaxes and Sadie definite programming
so again we start that we want to
maximize this quantity over this
discrete sector which is equivalent to
maximize the trace of a
great time X subject to the fact that X
is positive defined so all the
eigenvalues have no negative these are
an n times n matrix on the diagonal XII
is equal to 1 and X is of rank 1 because
essentially is the outer product of X of
small X by itself ok so this formulation
is equivalent to the original
formulation and now as DP relaxes the
run so instead of looking for the matrix
X of right one maximizing this was this
dysfunction this linear function because
now is a linear function in the in the
matrix X we relax the ramp can we
maximize this trace of a time times x
over the complex space of all of the
cone of all the semi definite progress
Emmy definite positive semi definite
matrices ok so these are a convex
optimization problem and once we find
the Maximizer which now is a matrix of
rank M where m can be between one and n
we have to project it back on a rank one
matrix and I will just find you in the
next slide how we do it so why do we
expect this to be better than at the
spectral relaxation essentially because
in among the mattresses that we are we
are studying we are sampling in order to
maximize this linear function we are
forcing all the diagonals to be one what
does it mean suppose that this matrix
now is representing the outer product of
the true Eden tall the infirmary shin
with itself the fact that along the
matrix is one this doesn't allow the
vector a small exa to localized because
if if it gets localized on the diagonal
you will have a heterogeneous you will
have the diagonal elemental which are
very much different so you are in Sun
sets forth in the system to produce a
solution which is almost ennis over the
graph ok so you avoid the localization
now how do we do this
in practice so in practice we have to
look for the maximum of a linear
function of a huge space of all the
mattresses okay and we want to do it an
efficient way so first of all you
realize that the rank em semi definite
the positive semi-definite matrices can
be written as a oops as correlation
matrices between variables X having n
components okay this immediately gives
you a column attics which has one along
the diagonals is positive semi definite
and so you just have to work in this
reduced space of matrices where m now is
a parameter you can set it to very large
or very small and I will show you that
you can play with that okay and then I
saw you try to maximize this quantity
which is nothing but the scalar product
between vectors of M components are
subject to this constraint do it Tina
and the simplest possible way as physics
would do it so zero temporal dynamics so
at each step we take one variable and we
online today to the local field in this
way we are doing steps that attend steps
we improve we we increase this dis
quantity okay finally once you find the
Maximizer which is now is a vector of n
em component by bolsa you compute the
empirical covariance matrix so you
compute the principal an eigenvector of
diseases so there is data in the
solution most of this vector so suppose
that you abba let me say aha a cluster
where which is very much connected in
this pattern and these are the two
communities the idea is that once you
find the optimizer most probably most of
these n components pins are roughly
align in this part and roughly align in
the other part and maybe some spin
between it's not a line ok so once you
see this blue configuration you want to
understand what is the principal
direction along which you want to
project the the eigenvector so you
compute the empirical covariance matrix
d gives you a direction which is this
one and then you project and you put all
these two minus one and all these two
plus one okay so this is the this the
idea and if you want to play with the
code you can find here a publicly
available code which I hope is is clear
enough to be used okay so and obviously
disagree all depends on the parameter m
so we are working with spin with M
components and in principle we obtain
the SDP convex objective function only
when n is equal to n while if we stick n
equal to 1 we have the original maximum
likely problem with discrete variables
ok so you see that the same function
changes drastically when you change this
parameter n for n equal one you are a
very rough objective function which
leads you to an np-hard problem for n
equal n you have a complex objective
function but actually you don't need to
go to n equal n because all ready for EM
larger the square root of n you can
prove that there are no local Maxima in
purdy recently and they also show that
for any n value and all the local minima
are close enough to the global mina by a
factor one of a square root of m so
there is that even for n small this
algorithm may work very well ok because
they the factual you want to optimize is
no longer so rough so maybe you can
optimize it easily and still the
algorithm is much faster because it is
linear in em ok ok in the running times
is very mild in in the size of the
system so let's see how it works ok so
now i'm taking a stochastic block model
various parts very close today today
today today de cultura shoulder and we
know cliques at all and the red line is
the expected the best overlap you can
shiv be a bias optima because it has
been computed via debate hashanah ok so
this day the best you can do in this
problem and you can see that if I'd you
can do should be obtained with BP ok I'm
lazy I run a habitation because I
according to your paper is very close to
the to the optimal go right so maybe the
Optima is a slightly above exactly where
we go with this data ok so this is the
result of a typical spectral method that
the most economic to use and there one
that I use now if m is equal one or two
you see that during the time of the
algorithm you are not able to achieve
the optimum you get stuck in some local
emphysema but if you increase em they
the convergence to the local to the
global maximum is faster and faster but
you don't need to go to him very large
like here this is 64 even for m equal 6
you approach very closely the global
maximum so you see that this objective
function already for a rather small
values of emma is very smooth
don't see of them participated and you
think where would you be like at this
value of lambda I don't know because we
are quite close to the to the critical
point I never runs away mean on this
problem certainly better than this
because this do temper than I so this is
the worst you can do by machinery you
will grow a little bit but exactly where
you go I haven't run it so I cannot
answer is yes so essentially here i have
dated 1000 time each vertex but i will
show you also actual times and is very
fast the other sensitive as in 30 number
of dimensions and be sufficient through
their glossary of you should ask a light
blue that person and what here you see
that for this size square root of n is
already 200 but we we have a very good
result even for m equal eight so it's
clearly not skin with them what i can
show you is that if you run this with
different size of the system such a the
values of M that you need the dots
kelvedon so they are really fine go
maybe scale like log n but it's really
enough to have very small values of Emma
to the algorithm work perfectly well and
the good news is that is very robust so
now we add a 10 to the minus 2 fraction
of click in the in the way I explain you
and while sorry a standard spectral
metal are not able to detect they need a
more Eden partition essentially you see
that the two curves obtained for M
equals 16 and six 16 and 64 sha don't
depend on on the value of alpha so it's
practically insensitive to the newly at
the noise emily is extremely fast if you
run it on this laptop for a size 10 to
the five you need the few seconds so you
can
solve a convex optimization problem with
the a million of variable in few seconds
on a laptop this is why we don't compute
any gradient we don't compute any action
we just do single variable update and
these are extremely fast ok now let's go
today to the second part of the total
and we like to convince you so this sdp
based algorithm is fast robusta and now
i want to convince you that is quazy
optimal so if we run it on a random and
sunblock problems where we know where is
the humanity I would like to convince
you that we are very close to the
technology using the same Shannon there
is this colossal so they also put some
some robustness side you can prove which
paper even but the better okay some
robustness is kind of open in values of
this right that if you change epsilon
fraction of the edges other changes and
multi-functional here is an optimization
problem so if you change ok yeah but
then the value of the objective function
you change the objective function by X
you know I cannot change more than
so what is the main thing that we like
to prove is that it exists a threshold
for this algorithm for SDP algorithm and
between a phase way essentially you
cannot detect anything to a phase where
you can detect something and actually in
our paper we we prove this first in a
simpler synchronization problem where
the matrix Y that you observe is dance
and it's made by summing a rank one
matrix with a random matrix which is the
noise and lambda represent the noise to
signal to noise ratio and depending
whether X are real or complex according
the the W matrix is filled with gastroc
investigation numbers and from the
observation why you would like to infer
the the signal XO and you can do it
using different statistical estimators
so you can do bias optimal by and
marginalizing over the posterior you can
use maximum likely by computing the the
dyad max of this function this quadratic
function or you can do a city which is
what I just tell you so find the matrix
X such that the maximized the linear
function a trace XY in the in the corner
of semi definite positive semi definite
matrices the nice thing is that okay and
you can convert this again as a problem
of maximization of a new function where
the variables X now lives in a
n-dimensional space the good thing is
that all these can be plugged in a
single unified framework in statistical
mechanics okay so essentially we study
just one a sadistic and mechanics
measure and from this taking different
limits we can recover all different
statistical estimator okay so the goal
now is to understand what's happening to
measure and from this we can infer the
the outcome of different statistical
inference okay and without surprised we
get the shutdown kapatic model that is
always I handed begun so in particular
for easy in variables up when you study
this function here for real variables is
equivalent to study this a miltonia
which is the asurion kapatic where the
couplings have a nonzero mean
proportional to the signal to noise
ratio and a variance which is 1 over N
okay so there is that here the signal is
the magnetization so if the if the model
if the measure has a nonzero
magnetization then it means by that by
that measure you can identify the data
partition okay and for example in the
temperature lambda phase diagram you
have a face which is the paramagnetic
cannot identify anything in it it
happens for small lambda you have a face
a ferromagnet where the magnetization
non zero and so you can identify the in
that partition you ever faced the spin
glass that you want to avoid because
it's NP hard ok and now m the bias line
that passes here and actually the full
face dagger it should consider the the
breaking of the replica symmetry and
what we know from the solution of the
shaded occupied model so you don't have
to solve again a model is that and we
have a phase transition in lambda lambda
critical equal to 1 but why in the bias
case it happened between two replicas
symmetric phases so we can same paliza
lee de de de measure at zero temporal
which corresponds to the maximum
likelihood estimator the phase
transition happened between two phases
which are replicas symmetry breaking so
is unlikely that we are able to sample
correctly the measure in a polynomial
time okay and so this makes the the the
maximum likelihood estimator
be hard okay so and we sold this model
in the dense case in the dense case by
this answers essentially so the main
answers it works like this it says each
variable locally feels local a magnetic
field X I that changes from side to side
socks I is a random variable is a gash
on random variable and moreover here's a
they fluctuate decorrelation the local
correlation are controlled by a matrix C
I because now locally you have a em
component variable so you the local
correlation are controlled by an N
buttons n matrix and what you find
essential is that in determining limit
this point it does not fluctuate so it
can be described by a unique matic c and
this quantity is a Gaussian vector we
that is fully described by the mean
vector mu and by the covariance matrix Q
and so you finally bright
self-consistent situation for these
three object a vector and two matrices
and you solve this adeva a different
values of lambda NM and you find the
solution and the solution looks like
this I'm talking here the mean square
error so they expected value of the well
the distance this minimizes already the
symmetries but is the distance between
the in fairport Ixchel and the original
transmission and you see that for lambda
smaller than one you cannot do best on a
random guess and then Atlanta equal one
you have a phase transition the Miss for
error decreases and the blue line is
what we get x SD p which is quite close
to the bias optimal which is the red
dashed line and definitely much better
than pca which is the blue dashed line
because at large lambda values PCA is
not exploiting the fact that the
solution must be on the integral
so ETA looks a fine sir solution of the
vertices okay and the points are
numerical simulation that you see that
already for not so large sizes are very
close to the dynamic limit so 8 10 12 so
we're a step or two away from the block
model here should i think these endlich
calculations are in the is densely meat
i will show you the stochastic block
Molina in a minute ok so now stochastic
model and we read it two things a first
that we are deeply based algorithms so
we take the algorithm we run it for we
are very large value of n much so like
if we are really doing sdp on the corner
of positive semi definite matrices if m
is large enough there is no dependence
on a map but since this is quite hairy
to do because we know that the agar is
very faster with very small Emma but if
you take em 100 or he takes some time
then we also proved propose an
approximate and salsa which is exciting
the large delimiter and still provides
are quite good answer also for finite d
so i will show you the result of these
two so this the results for the
stochastic block model with equal 5 and
this landed in a signal to noise ratio
so the idea is that up to a certain
critical value that we have to compute
the the the overlap is 0 then becomes
different from 0 and the points are what
we get running the algorithm the actual
algorithm and the black line is the
approximate analytical solution so I
would say that is approximate very well
at least here then close to criticality
and we have to be careful diosa now
let's try to to compute better the
critical point how do we do when
essentially we ran they are grilled the
actual algorithm four different sizes
for many many samples because as you
know who this simulation of the
disordered system there are
huge sample to sample fluctuation if you
want to achieve a very high precision
you have to run a huge number of samples
and this is a quantity called being the
cumin that must cross at the critical
point so you see they are indeed cross
singer and if you'd luma and you run
even better simulation with larger sizes
you see that the cross singer of the
actual behavior of the algorithm so it's
very close to the number we get from the
approximate analytical solution that I i
will describe you in the next slide and
so these our best estimates for the
algorithmic threshold for SDP run on
stochastic block model with min degree 5
which doesn't mean that is able to find
that the EDA partition as long as lambda
is larger than this value which is less
than two percenter worse than the
optimal one which is one how's this to
do i will show you the a plotter already
on the answer to your question i hope so
now they approximate the analytical
solution if you want to solve this
problem I in principle you want to solve
their let me say the BP equation for
this problem at least at the replica
symmetric level the words that we are
working with the variables live in una M
dimensional sphere okay so you would
like to parameterize with few numbers as
in a good mean field approximation the
measure of a after a sphere this is not
easy okay and so I am writing here the
most general & sats we use that already
contains quite a good number of
parameters and there is the following
since we are interesting the situation
where the OM symmetry gets broken along
one direction because if if we identify
the signal the simile gets broken
immediately from the beginning we take
the variables X and we divide two
sectors one variable s along the
direction where the symmetry will get
broken and an orthogonal vector arena m1
minus one dimensional space which looks
like
get the random path to the random
orthogonal part and then on s we we use
a while always at the exponential we use
a quadratic function and on the
orthogonal part that we use the same
answers we use in the dense case so
essentially at the measure depends only
on the scalar product with a random
vector and then we try to close and the
random vector is a Gaussian with this
and distribution and then we try to
close on the number c h and r which are
our three parameter three parameter per
side okay this answer should be
correcting the to limit in the two
extreme and limit high degree and DV
code close today to the percolation
threshold then you take this answer you
plug into the cavity method and you
derive a self-consistent situation you
sold by population dynamics I you
compute the mean overlap with the true
partition function and what you get is
something like this so it's zero up to
here and different from zero so it works
quite well but even better we now since
I would like to understand that when
this becomes different from zero I can
do some kind of linear approximation
because here all day this parameter are
small some of this parameter a small and
so if you do linear approximation in a
in h which is the quantity which is
small you can convince yourself that
they are which is the term of the
quadratic term is zero and so you end up
with simpler equation which are linear
and so you can try to understand when
this linear equation becomes unstable
which correspond to the critical point
and doing this well this is the solution
i will show you justice so this the rate
actually is this quantity here so is
tell you the director of growing of the
linear part so as long as it is zero
they fix the somatic fixed point where
the Oyam symmetry has not been broke
is stable beyond this point the OM
symmetry gets spun tanner is broken so
this is the critical point for the
appearance of a non zero magnetic sure
in the direction of the hidden partition
and so these our analytical approximate
estimator of the critical point you can
compare the red points which is what we
compute with running the actual
algorithm with a black curve which is
our estimates through the analytical
approximate solution and their two are
quite close i consider that for large DD
mask on side so here everything is going
fine here they are quite close and most
importantly we respect to the optimal
treasure which is one we are always less
than two percent off so this algorithm
for the stochastic model can recognize
the hidden partition in the worst case
when lambda is larger than this curve
which is not more than 2% words the
optimal value ok I think that it's time
to finish and so let me just recap the
take-home messages so as if these are
especially for physicists oh I I'm
thinking what I would like to know two
years ago before starting working on
this so sdp relaxation are extremely
effective I didn't know this before as a
physics and I think that many pieces are
not aware of this they are robust was
the optimal and they may also perform
spectral relaxation in many cases even
better than SD p RS DP inspire algorithm
so if instead of using m equal to
infinity use more m this is even better
and obviously doing the theory for data
maybe is harder but for practical
application is extremely powerful
finally is another table message for
physics that we have to study these
models with em component variables
because we know much much less than the
easing
models but they have a different physics
and most probably they will provide us
with better algorithms so okay is much
harder but is worth doing it and I thank
you for your attention
already many this is the output so I
couldn't put the retinal guarantees for
solving these kind of realizations that
so they broke the quartz dimensional
vector wafers and where the illusion is
because it's a national charts ready to
to your evolution like the depth of Lee
I didn't explain well how do we have all
their that's all how do we maximize the
objective function right so it's a
pretty simple blue space basis already
come to continue some random box on the
underground did you know it is I don't
know if this work but what we did there
is is a very simple updating rule that
is a very effective because what you
have to maximize this function in n
variables with n component each so it's
not an easy objector and the voice that
if you start computing a gradient it
takes quite a lot of time even computing
the gradient even in the Indus pass k so
actually what we do is we take we do the
following I at each time and you can
compute consider this variable which is
interacting with other variables and
each variable as its own spin in an
m-dimensional and so all these variables
are producing a field on this variable
here and at each time regardless of the
value that is variable us at this moment
we compute the local field which is
maybe here is something like this I
don't know if there is a majority
pointing up and we align the variable
which is of unitary normal with the
field this is actually a very fast is
like saying we do a coordinate wise
ascent but with advantage that on each
coordinate we already know where is the
maximum so on each step we maximize in
one coordinate while when you compute
the gradient then you have to do a step
you don't know what is the maximum you
should come
shin-bi computation is is impossible
with it because it takes too much time
so if you don't want to compute the
shanna then if you use the Graduate you
have to do a step but adaptive step you
don't know where is the maximum here you
are doing something much simpler so you
take one coordinate that you maximize
one other corner you maximize and in s n
steps of this which is our let me say
one more one montecarlo step is an
update of this type you do better than
going along the gradient and it takes
more or less the same time because
computing one gradient is like doing n
of the of these updates and so this
makes the algorithm extremely faster it
is different from what you were saying
but we respect to wee-wee program
different the way of maximizing the
function this one looks really there the
fastest is the key feature that you know
me like to know the direction we we
align the variable variables are all
normal one because of a white the
diagonal of the matrix is not one so we
take the variables which are normal one
and we align to the local field and this
is the best you can do so in this way
you are maximizing the objective
function coordinate wise block or data
set I don't know where the block comes
from the sploagie update Empire ah for
that not for me is one variable he's
aware he's an M component very own and
understand where the block so from your
questions